this is cereth is Turner's orange calm
and in this video I'm going to show you
how to assess visual acuity using a
Snellen chart whenever you do this
you're assessing cranial nerve 2 which
is the optic nerve and of course
whenever you perform the skill you will
need a Snellen chart now we're going to
test visual acuity using a Snellen chart
and what you're gonna do is you're gonna
have your patients and about 20 feet
from the chart so Ben if you'll stand
about right there for me
and ask your patient do you wear glasses
ok and if your patient does wear glasses
you'll want them to wear those for this
test ok so what we're gonna do look at
that chart over there and try to read
the lowest line for me that you can read
ok and first we're gonna cover your
right eye then your left eye and then
we'll do both eyes ok so cover your
right eye ok and what line can you read
ok read it for me ok very good ok now
we're going to cover up your left eye
and do the same thing and again whatever
line you can read let me know 8 again ok
the C ok and now read with both eyes and
what line ok ok and he read from line 8
so that means that he has 20/20 vision
and this means that he can see the same
line of letters at 20 feet that a person
with normal vision can see at 20 feet
however let's say that in his left eye
he could only read like line 6 which is
2030 that would mean that his left eye
sees at 20 feet that a person with
normal vision would see at 30 okay so
that is how you assess visual
using a Snellen chart thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos